hi I'm Jessica Clemens and welcome back
to new rock stars quantumania's post
credit scene gave us so many King
variants and I wanted to scream I'm so
truly in love with Jonathan Majors as
Kang that I'd let Lizard King even get
it my love for him run so deep but this
video isn't about how the Lizard King
scales do it for me it's about the
Council of Kings plan all together we
know a mortis fears us entering the
Multiverse and taking everything they've
worked so hard for which is
understandable I would be pissed as well
but how can he be stopped how Army of
Kings control non-kang variants from
venturing into the Multiverse because
haven't we already done that have we
already done that already in this video
I'll be going over the Council of Kings
plan ultimately and how they can succeed
but how we can succeed as well we as in
the good guys not me because I'm on
King's side so I'm not a good guy let's
get into it we last left off in
quantumania after Kang the Conqueror Was
Defeated he was pulled into the energy
core and left dead allegedly after Scott
Ponders if the world is really safe
right now we get our first mid-credits
scene with the Council of Kings these
are the men who are behind banishing
King the Conqueror it's a mortise the
Egyptian pharaoh Rama touch in the
Scarlet Centurion these three lead the
Thousand Army Kang variants immortus
fears that now everyone other than
themselves are able to touch the
Multiverse there's no time for waiting
around and they must act so they summon
all the king variants from different
timelines to help fight those that can
enter the Multiverse now we don't know
if this mid-credit scene even takes
place right after the movie they entered
the quantum realm really so I'd argue
that Multiverse and Madness was truly
the wake-up call mortis needed to
actually be afraid of so this scene
could be as early is phase four or might
be before Kang Dynasty because time is
finicky when kings are involved anyways
there's clearly a weird hierarchy
amongst the kangs whether they know it
or not the core 3 looked to be Scarlet
Centurion ramita and amortis ramatut
feels like the center of a lot of King
stories because he went back to being
ramadet a couple of times he started as
Nathaniel Richards board in his timeline
so he built a sphinx looking time
machine and went to ancient Egypt and
was able to take over their Kingdom his
goal there was basically to groom
apocalypse the mutant to be his Heir
then the Fantastic Four arrived in
ancient Egypt and Ramada enslaved them
then the West Coast Avenger showed up
and they were also defeated konchu later
saved the West Coast Avengers and
ramadet's Men turned on him everything
was like failing so he escaped in his
time machine but wound up messing that
up too and popped out in the 20th
century later becoming Scarlet Centurion
he's gone back to being ramadet again in
the comics after failing as the Scarlet
Centurion which leads me to the Scarlet
Centurion the scar Centurion was
originally ramadet and once he escaped
he met Dr Doom and inspired by Dr Doom
created a suit like his and called
himself the Scarlet Centurion the scar
Centurion had convinced The Avengers in
the comics to turn on they have other
heroes or else the world would end
because there were so many superheroes
he even had them fight the Avengers of
689 in a different reality once defeated
by Goliath he was sent back into the
time stream he deemed the Centurion as
another failure and became ramadet again
but because he was immediately shot into
the time stream it created a Divergent
AKA variant Scarlet Centurion now this
Scarlet Centurion was actually
successful in his Endeavors there's also
a Scarlet Centurion that's the son of
Nathaniel Richards who took on the
moniker so there's like three different
scar centurions we could be looking at
then lastly there's a mortise Kang and
ramita eventually become a mortise
Ramadan and limbo aspiring to retire and
sequester himself as the Lord of limbo
and the master of time he took on the
identity of a mortise since limbo
basically exists outside time and space
there is no age in him a mortis's Sly
and likes to dupe people he's a master
manipulator rather than forcing people
to do his will so looking at their
Marvel stats each of them have a seven
for Speed and intelligence four but
energy durability and fighting skills
differ it's probably because of mortise
spends most of his time in limbo barely
fighting people because he can
manipulate anything there while we're on
the set literally had to fight in Egypt
though they're all the same person their
identities differ and have different
stats which play into them working
together or eventually splitting up
that's all the kings or well those are
the three kings so what's the plan
overall a lot of people have given up on
being good at sleep but that's only
because they don't realize what a
difference good sleep gear Makes You Can
level up your sleep game overnight with
a helix sleep Helix sleep makes premium
mattresses embedding customized to fit
your needs and shipped right to your
door I know that that man brought it up
to my door and I am ever grateful for
him forever and look I'm not a
sleepologist or anything but I don't
need to be Helix has a sleep quiz that
matches your unique body type and sleep
preference to the perfect mattress for
you you can even take it with a partner
and find the mattress that's perfect to
compromise between your preferences and
that's very important because I like to
roll over people in my sleep I took the
quiz I wanted a medium firm mattress
with lumbar support that sleeps cool and
I got matched with the dusk Luxe Helix
mattress I've had it for a few months
and I love it and I will never get rid
of it sleep better and wake up less
often than I used to and let me tell you
I used to wake up in the middle of the
night screaming Helix delivers your
mattress right to your door for free you
guys I can't emphasize enough how it's
for free and they deliver it to your
door because it's a big heavy mattress
it comes rolled up in a shockingly tiny
box and it's super easy to set up
yourself you just open it and Helix has
a 100 night sleep trial so you'll get
more than three months to make sure that
you love your mattress if you don't
they'll pick it up for you and you'll
get a full refund which is better than
what anywhere else could give you and
these mattresses also have a 10 year
warranty that's an entire decade you
guys Helix even has a financing option
and flexible payment plan so a great
night's sleep is never too far away I
love my Helix and I think you would too
if you're looking for a new bed check
out Helix you can click the link below
or go to Helix sleep.com new rockstars
and get 20 off your Helix mattress plus
two free pillows why are the Kings doing
this we need to take a look at he who
remains in King the Conqueror to get a
better understanding he who remains
isolated his timeline and created the
TVA to manage the flow of time and
prevent any further branches this stops
his evil variants from coming and taking
it over right so King the Conqueror
though he could be lying said he was
exiled for trying to stop the other
versions of himself from destroying the
Multiverse he said time is broken
because of his variants throughout the
Multiverse they play with time like
children he saw How It Ends their chaos
spreading universes colliding and
endless incursions he saw the Multiverse
dying so he took control he's trying to
rebuild what's broken by conquering it
uh just like a super evil motive now we
could say the Council of King's plan is
that they solely care only about
conquering and not at all about the
incursions or killing timelines but I
think they're too smart for that they'll
recognize if that's their sole plan
which of them will end of the true
conqueror there could only be one we
always know there can only be one and if
you believe that that's their plan
respect for you I believe it ultimately
but deeper down it's bigger than that it
has to be there's an interesting point
to be made that most Kings think alike
and they're under the impression or
their motive is that in order to fix
what's broken you must be in control of
it first so with that motivation they
probably think that what they're doing
is Justified even when it's bad they
think they're protecting their world
from their worst outcome which is
themselves I think as of right now
amortis is planting the seed the Earth
616 has Heroes that can kill Kings and
now their move is to find that planet in
that specific timeline and stop all who
can stop them from across the Multiverse
a mortise could be running this entire
show and duping everyone he mentions at
the end of the movie none of us killed
him they did there'd be beginning to
touch the Multiverse if we let them they
will take everything we built so let's
stop wasting time he's already planting
in their minds paranoia and rushing them
to attack by using the Council of Kings
to pave the way and ultimately fight to
the death either by The Avengers or one
another it will leave a mortise as the
last one in the comics the Council of
Kings was created to destroy other kings
to begin with they hand-picked other
kings to kill and take over their
Empires then found out it was all
manipulated by immortus eventually the
council eliminated all versions of
themselves and Prime Kang destroyed the
council members we could literally see
that happening here with amortis could a
bunch of Kings really trust each other
absolutely not are they Their Own Worst
Enemy 100 I truly believe that mortise
is the leader not only because he is the
center of the king Council he's choosing
when to strike that's leader Behavior
101. I think it's a mortise play in them
all like a fiddle to The Curtain Call
and right now we're only seeing the
beginning which is them exiling the bad
kings and keeping the Allied ones how
can we really stop them you know let's
take a look at the movies in the series
coming up in Phase five and six to find
out we know we make it to Kang Dynasty
and some variant would probably spill
into Secret Wars I think we can also see
variants pop up in Guardians of the
Galaxy vol 3 Loki season 2 Agatha
Covenant chaos and definitely the
Fantastic Four Guardians of the Galaxy
will be dealing with the high
evolutionary who some believe could be a
Kang variant but I agree with mt on an
episode of Rogue Theory someone who is
so transfixed on building the perfect
being and also a genius in genetics they
had to have met before in the past
Kane's built robots in Herbert Wyndham
Ultra genetic codes even the high
evolutionaries Marvel stats are superior
to Kings put on the king variant be
interested in whoever this is well
absolutely as for Loki season 2 we
already got a glimpse of Victor timely
in the Stinger for quantumania with our
baby boys lokia Mobius I don't think
Victor will be the only King variant we
see in Loki season 2. if Sylvia is alive
and hell bent on killing Kings she's
gonna be killing some Kings as for
Agatha Covenant of chaos when Agatha had
access to the dark hole she knew the
damaging effects the Scarlet Witch would
leave behind what if a king variant just
wrote the dark hole what if he who
remains who knows all has many names
knows how everything works wrote that in
a book to be found eons later he's been
called everything right like it makes
sense that he could just write a book or
maybe there is a okay that has chaos
magic this is something that can be
explored in Agatha coven of chaos and
then Fantastic Four they better run into
some King variants and easily stop them
as they do time and time again in the
comics additionally if one of the Kang
variants was Doctor Doom we could just
go with it I love it if they don't
defeat Kang in those series they're
still superheroes that exist outside of
them that can still defeat Kang we know
Scott and hope with the help of some
ants can absolutely defeat a king we saw
it Scarlet Witch easily in the comics
that's why amortis wanted her she can
literally step into the Multiverse
through another version of her own body
doctor strange and Wong with the help of
the Mystic Arts absolutely could take on
Kang variants Loki clearly with the help
of Sylvie I mean she already killed one
in the comics konshu has defeated
ramitet so by proxy we could see Moon
Knight defeating a variant I'm sure with
much assistance America Chavez can make
it quicker by sending people into
different universes to fight alongside
her I personally believe that Captain
Marvel could also defeat a king variant
with her energy manipulation and healing
factors I'm sure there's absolutely more
especially because it looks like the
mcu's setting up as a team you can take
him down he's definitely not Unstoppable
in the comics that's why he's jumped
around so much he's been defeated all
the time but it will take more than one
person to do so that's it for my video
on the Council of King's plans and how
we can defeat them I feel like this will
be stretch over phase five and more
information will be sprinkled in later
but for now we can theorize and baby I
think a mortise is the heart and soul of
this operation follow me on Instagram
and Twitter at Lulu underscore Clemons
follow new Rockstar subscribe to new
Roxas from her breakdowns of everything
you love thanks for watching see you
later
foreign
[Music]